it was a dark and spooky night and
everyone came back to the video that
they were just watching a little bit ago
because it's here now and everybody's
happy so welcome back to dark scary cam
stories at night I don't really know
it's late and I'm still making videos
for Subway wait
I've never been so happy to see your
face actually I don't think I've ever in
happens come on what he being so mean to
wait just look at it but this time I am
where's Bab Bob's in the hall what did
he fall come on I'll show you
oh I don't trust wait here is he okay
hey you look kind of twitchy are you
okay you have to stay strong all right
the body-snatching spirit is here right
we need to check Bob what does that
smell by the way you smell worse than
normal Wade yeah not suspicious at all
yes I shall follow blindly wait wait
what about this styrofoam come on mark
down here I'll show you okay wait okay
cool I wonder if I really could have
tried the styrofoam pieces on him
because wait crumb maybe I can still cry
that word I'll just hang on to this
until I can find a cozy trashcan to drop
it well what about Wade there give up a
little test to make sure he's still him
so Bob just fell in through this hole
what's that mouse cursor there the whole
time I really apologize if it was okay
so it actually was not there so I'm good
to go and I don't need to worry about
anything because just stop it recording
and all my rhythm is gone but hey we're
going into a giant hole so who doesn't
like that I don't know how what wow I
guess that's what I was going for okay I
gotta look for myself in this giant hole
wait don't push me in this hole oh no is
this your hole no there we go I got
pushed in the hole sex jokes hole jokes
I don't know jokes jokes
oh this don't look good I'm gonna go
with ouch as well as what the hell Wade
looks like there's only one place to go
how about over here it's a rock good
find buddy thanks me
I love me oh that sounds weird
let's just go forward and ignore that
ever happen hello who are you Bob Wade
oh it wasn't you huh
but if you're here you couldn't defend
the Body Snatcher guy so why it wasn't
me mark I'm the real me and I'm the real
me we're really us you guys are acting
strange and I still smell that putrid
stick wood I better shoot you both in
the head just to be sure
wait I don't have a gun I better punch
you in the gonads just to be sure
skinwalkers the wait I met was a
skinwalker pretending to be Wade okay
then so how do I know if you guys are
really popping Wade of course we are
lead us out of here we'll be right
behind you come on let's go home now I
can't lead skinwalkers back home I'll
have to do some questioning anyone who
throws up a red flag is getting dropped
into that hole what I'm satisfied I'll
exit whoever I decide is alright can
come along with me all right we'll go
but I need a minute to rest and pull the
styrofoam out of my back
I could use these to see if it's a real
Wade but if it is you might have a heart
attack or something I better try what
what No okay fine
let's have some soup hello I am Bob
would you like to do question Bob tell
me something an imposter wouldn't know
okay weight is a big dummy everyone
knows that do better we used to roll
sushi together in Cincinnati Holi the
real Bob would remember that right
we never rolled sushi hmm we never
rolled sushi
hey Mark
tell me something a posture wouldn't
know okay after you lost your first
channel we talked about the future on a
balcony we talked about it for nearly an
hour nearly three hours how could an
impostor remember that important night
mark hmm we didn't roll sushi but then
again I have to question the developer's
knowledge of how detailed they to
remember things we worked in a sushi
restaurant but that doesn't mean that we
actually made sushi
[Music]
I don't know why rummy I mean they seem
okay
but then against someone who could have
just watched my videos would have known
that
like the developer okay let's wait for
me don't leave me here okay I guess I
guess they're good Oh
sabotage TV even tricks perhaps the
memories your friends were oh come on I
knew they were a little off you suck Bob
we didn't roll sushi together Chris Bob
miss Gwen's for you how's dirt taste ah
good choice
I'm the real one okay alright then is it
still gonna be sampled house no you're
right yeah yeah I know what it was but I
didn't want to be too anal retentive
about it so does that mean that Bob is
just maybe he got that wrong about Bob
you should need underwear
oh-ho-ho you made a hilarious joke and
the right choice now let's get the hell
out of here it's still gonna be sabotage
I want to see how I'm wrong about this
yeah yeah I knew it sabotage Bob Bob and
Dave workers I know this it's my life
bon jovi thank you
all right push them both in corn ooh
wait no no no no no no no push him in
good job me clamp laughs hooray they're
both dead now neither of you can fool me
apparently they can three times actually
Oh
huh oh no Bob and Bob mark what the hell
is that thing is that really how it look
from this angle
very funny jerk mark kill that thing
okay I can tell that one of these is the
real Bob it might be a true friend
intuition or maybe just necessary to
advance the blood we leave through the
wrong door will be crushed I heard them
talking about it wait which one said
that the real Bob wouldn't lie to me
it's game whopper Bob is capable of only
lies however it tells the opposite of
what is true oh boy we got a riddle here
so using my supreme intellect I will
choose the honest Bob incorrect or while
I'm at it though I'm not sure which I
should figure out first
maybe if I decide on a door first I can
attempt to exit and use what the Bob's
have to say as a way to figure out which
one's a real one all right guys give me
a minute
you just wait patiently don't worry
about me paint if written rose fire
ready one little web it's a bright blue
bye buddy it's rock blue bye buddy I
don't rain on writer especially one with
a nightmare bubble web okay so
not yet well how am I supposed to figure
out which door is which okay then all
right
hey bark talk Bob I'm the real Bob that
thing over there is some shapeshifter we
all need to shift it into shape of this
plaid at the bottom of the head then you
and I can leave and find our way back as
soon as we find Wade I haven't seen the
real Wade in this cave since I've been
down here though as for which door we
should take I don't actually know which
is the correct door that thing over
there knows is lying to you it's all
right now push that liar into the pen so
we can leave Yeah right I'm the real Bob
that thing over there is a monster and
is creeping me right the hell out you
should kill it if you push it into the
hole and leave with me we can find Wade
and get out of here and so ready to get
away from this smelly place he smells a
smelly smell that smells smelly so
therefore he must know the smelly smells
of the smell Walker's I don't know which
is the right door however them talking
earlier though if you were to ask the
other Bob he'd say door 4 is the wrong
door I'll have a bad feeling about door
number 2
I don't know why but I don't like it so
I know kill that thing let's get the
hell out of here
so this one smells a smelly smell oh you
nasty other babies say door 4 is the
wrong door but this guy knows that other
guy says that this guy knows what the
real door is I have a bad feeling about
door number 2 I don't know why but I
don't like it so I know okay does that
all I have to go on is all I have to go
hon rare and elusive talk there's no
other clues in here eh
I have a feeling that this one's the NIM
posture just based on the smelly smells
alone I mean I'm good at discerning from
smelling smells so perhaps there would
be something else if smell smelly smell
eNOS do but I don't know I'm supposed to
determine which one's weird know about
door number 2 but if he's the right one
then he would not definitely not want to
not go that way but you say door 4 is
the wrong door therefore maybe doing is
right door I choose door far gonna leave
me are you sure that's the right door no
that's the wrong door but if you're sure
of it okay posture careful day off that
was really Bob knows that he'll do you
bother nice now let's get out of here of
course through door for those happen
sighs OH
oh god damn it holy [ __ ] am I really
seeing this right now how many ways is
that
I count seven one and I'm air one way to
stand I'm air to be around but weighed
Sevenfold
what level of hell have we descended to
hello guys he knows me I'm sure I
buzzing real wait you're all posers Big
B guys dogs are so crazy they hate to be
an echo but lies are all Bonjour job
Wade so happy to see me I'm the real
Wade hey Wade you got a tan I feel like
one of you is maybe the real way maybe
I'm David I'm not some Android wait what
guys calm down I'll bring that blade dog
sees abysses this qualifies as desperate
times I believe it's time for desperate
measure wouldn't you say huh I believe
so hope I picked the right Bob how do I
know if I did okay come on guys I figure
the ma'am madly fibbing Wade's in this
muddy funkin cave
don't let these fools rule you the real
Wade it's me
okay so weird pick me and let's go javi
oh this isn't helping there has to be
another way you're right there has to be
another way
don't know all these puzzles I can't
leave the real way bind but why not oh
of course not to do it dumb I forgot
about this
sorry I have to do this real wait
there's our way now let's get out of
here quick okay bye everybody else how
do I know if I got the real Bob the
bridge was bad news I thought the bad
news has gotta be let skinwalkers chose
a pretty lame person to imitate hey you
really have to use a styrofoam thing
kidding me you just left me to die with
a bunch of other monsters oh okay what
didn't I ask Bob a question I'm pretty
sure that was right just based on the
smelly smells but if I'm wrong I'm gonna
feel really really really bad
that's your bedtime Wade I'm sure your
fire would be nice but I'm more focused
getting out of here not dying to be
honest my voice change from a bad ass to
it even based on what we've seen so far
I don't want to know what's in this
thing looks like the researchers
described this place I'll stick my hand
in monster guts but spooky backs hello
oh my god somebody spilled something
could save this table Kirby is this poor
little stool
okay Yatta Yatta Yatta Yatta crap crap
crap blah blah blah something's Bob
might say about totally unremarkable
table I've never seen these beds when
there's epic orgy ever made hey what
does that supposed to mean Ron finish
this thing it's almost attenders
republishes this handy to maybe hear of
styrofoam the time it takes Alvin this
isn't worth getting home that much
sooner
okay alrighty then
so what else am I supposed to see here
net ass dead fish in it back so smells
better than skinwalkers hey he smells a
smelly smell alrighty then he knows he
knows what's up we all know what's up
we're what's up in what what's what's
what in the butt okay all right we got
to go back to cam now I got to be sure
that I didn't just kill Bob I know it's
like whatever shall we do I'm a helpless
video game camera guy leave
okay can I go back down you back up when
I'm near this hole wait for me one says
well but it twice and I'm and campsite
let's just grab the league's we gotta
have and come back tomorrow when the
Sun's up for the rest the only important
thing I brought is the keys you guys
grab your stuffing oh oh oh what we
don't have keys what do you mean you
drop them back there with the
skinwalkers no before the fake version
of you led us through the ditch a super
fast creature snatch them out of my
hands I forgot in all the excitement I
didn't realize it was a fake me
wandering around here that means one of
those things came into my tent without
me knowing the creature ran off to the
west towards the river I guess I saw her
best man for runs the keys dig is that
there's a cave back that way well with
the lantern we should have be able to
investigate navigate it enough to find
the keys
how do you know for sure the creature
went into the cave because of course did
very enough I don't want to go in the
cave what's this right here I'll hold
down the fort yeah yeah we wouldn't want
the campsite to float away while you're
gone mark will hold it down really
you're gonna make me go alone yup they
all bubble-blowing babies fine I'll go
get the keys from the hellish demon in
the dark cave while you guys stand
around away
oh but it's dangerous to go alone damn
damn oh thanks I guess jerks where's
tiny Buxton you better be the real Bob
woo moral support I'm helping that
sounds very good real Bob well at least
I know I what I'd look like ass black
man oh you weren't just town you were
actually on African American gentleman
okay so oh I gotta say please let me say
please let me save I need to save so bad
okay so I've been through the north and
the south I think the West is the only
thing that's left in this game so long
as I chose all the right options which I
may or may not have but we'll find out
soon enough
hey howdy do
watch where you're falling thing nearly
crushed me how dare it I should crush it
with my oh it's dark oh no this is
lovely
oh wow that's actually like just like
that's actually light displacement in
here it's really cool ah crap I did that
wrong oh crap welp that's it for me then
okay where am I going with all this what
am i doing okay there we go
did I just do myself I saw that hey I
saw that doe won't come mess with the
likes of me ain't gonna turn out so good
for you
meaning that I'm gonna beat you into a
pulp and then you're not gonna be
recognizable by your own mom it should
be really sick Hey okay what's this on
the wall some kind of fish scales but
they have hair - got scales could these
be where fish scales I should have known
I suspected it all along hey oh boy here
we go
okay can't go it that way push through
here ah damn it did I just done a goof
I just goofed crap crap crap crap I
crapped up try it again hopefully this
actually resets cuz that would be tragic
okay so I need to do obviously this is
the first choice but then you
push this out there we go okay it was
actually relatively simple I got it I
got it I got it what's sound up a bone
xylophone
oh it's Oliver or was it a bone
xylophone that's what I'm really
wondering I'm wondering if there's a
bone each like xylophone xylophone er
okay looks like I can't go back that way
good oh no not another page what is this
an old shopping list
milk yarn and cardboard box can a weirdo
made this list and anyway there should
be just enough room for me to scribble
on this torn up disgusting sheet of
paper well there we go was not the
nastiest thing I've been forced to
autograph is it though is it really I
have an autograph that many nasty things
it's still weird considering that I've
autographed okay so where am I going now
where am I going where am I going okay
not this way obviously what about this
other way back over here did this lead
anywhere yes it did seems like this
would lead back towards the afters the
keys could be further ahead okay so
that's my escape route once I come back
running screaming like a big baby from
all the diabolical monsters I want to
eat my face on other parts of me no okay
dead ends again the left side seems to
be a lot of dead ends but maybe this is
a dead end too
yep dead end great ain't afraid to no
spider good for you markiplier good for
you knowing there's that bone xylophone
again the bone isla phone the lies I'll
alone a bone boner
wells isla bone would have been the most
appropriate but I didn't think about
that time Oh judge me okay where the
Frick am I going okay I should just
guess I guess I should just keep
pressing forward because oh hey well hey
there it's a skeleton a dead one a dead
skeleton I can't believe it okay I
acquired Wade's car keys now if I can
just get out of here without attracting
attention of any horrible monsters
oh okay that usually works since doing
back here I don't know but I like it
wait I don't even want to know who is
the fire burning in here get out of here
before he finds me around a whole lot
okay I guess I did
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why was that wrong why was that wrong I
know how to go I went to get here is
apparently not the way I thought I did
do and do not
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight Oh dad right there right there
right there right down at down dad I
hope everyone's enjoying us because this
is fun time
[Music]
oh you poor baby boo boo me that music
very intense very very intense I did it
almost there keep running exactly the
thing there we go that's ticket
oh this effort to get out of a terrible
place father wait are you still you and
you know the keys they'll thank you Wade
yeah Wade what the hell you didn't help
either he gave me his torch
it's my torch so I helped ya but I
handed it to him it's okay that you
didn't want to help Wade
next time you move someone else can help
you with the furniture
whoa yeah Wade useless hi hello friend
you naked you idiot
this guy again do I know you you don't
know me but I don't hang out with videos
like you give me hot dog
excuse me what makes you think you can
talk to him that way why you guys do it
and how long have we you known Wade I
don't know yeah this is the moral of the
story we gave away a hard time because
he's our friend
we men can make jokes because we love
him and he knows it oh yeah I loved way
too we go back get lost
well thanks guys we you don't have to
shut up this isn't about you you guys is
jerks I just want a damn hot dog what
just cuz you pay for amazing yours may I
ask Jacob you got three seconds
alright well as you please man you know
what after the night I had I thank you
for this really I'm very strong thanks
for sticking up for me no problem let's
get out of here
it's gonna grab my diary and then I'll
be ready to go
oh oh you okay in there yeah I just had
to punch myself in the nards yo to wake
me up no I sell my damn toe out do over
it we gotta move Oh was that the
skinwalker I feel bad for not helping in
the cave it's not like we didn't help at
all we've had quite the adventure
tonight too so I'm I'm so ready to go
okay let's get out of here it's me
[Music]
one last round of quizzing to make sure
no one was a skinwalker and then back
home oh my homey home yeah okay who
would even cut I call it four in the
morning oh it's four in the morning is
it no I need some meat in my mouth
please
thing is hideous any door closes
something better for the third game I
need the moment assume rest okay okay
okay do I need to go to the poopoo okay
all right here why am i laughing here we
go here we go for what I've been away
from my new home
I just grown comfortable but I had to
leave for a while I wasn't ready for it
yet but now I am I've been studying
I learned a lot with Bob and way tonight
listen carefully whenever anyone spoke I
can do now what I couldn't do before
oh come on he was too strong for me to
take his body from him again but I got
lucky
found a way to get what I wanted
[Music]
what the hell mark why'd you push this
down here I could have broken my neck
ouch idiots what the hell are you
oh he possessed a skinwalker i'm marga
blaggard hey Peggy Mark's body was going
to be quite the challenge luckily a
skinwalker did it for me there's stupid
creatures able to mimic but now I'm a
capable emerge beyond their it didn't
find me at all after I I'm the body I
just had to replace a real ocular and
head home with its clueless oh no I'm
dead you came there no markiplier stop
dude mark mark oh I get it I get it
[Music]
[Music]
all right yay there better be some sweet
sweet revenge that's why I was doing all
right
I already knew but hey I'm awake now I'm
alive not dead what happened I thought
we were about to leave wait
was all of that just a dream did I have
another crazy nightmare
probably not oh hey wow what are the
odds of that who are you again I'm John
and she's Geralyn where J squared
productions we've met like this once
before yes we have here the developer of
this game oh you guys nice to see you
again Sarah by the way dear I'm confused
as to what's going on I don't think
anyone else is here ours is the only car
pinkest damn it they left we here pretty
you two doing here
we're not skinwalkers yeah yeah huh
we're gonna look for wildlife and walk
the trails in you know park stuff do you
need a ride home yes I need to go home
please
oh we just got here your house is such a
long drive from here too look if you
guys money please
I gave Slenderman all my money I don't
have any left wait I can't give you any
money
Oh see ha smart smart smart huh whoa
that guy's copy written now
the monster you encountered must have
been a parody which is totally legal by
the fair use laws Oh fun fact I drew
that spray myself myself in an let's
paint hope you like meeting him not so
much
well we can take you home but I can call
you marque poof I want to okay so there
all the other fangirls can use that one
too I called myself Marquis mu Marquis
Phu sounds slightly less appealing thank
you so much it's only been a day but I'm
super homesick
you think being a king of the squirrels
would have helped me out here but the
monsters have scared them all away it's
been tough
don't be too hard on me in the final
chapter of this trilogy okay hmm how
about a small teaser after the credits
button leave you didn't switch over to
easy mode you didn't right that was it
was that my phone alarm was going off
well all right then I guess we're
waiting for the epic conclusion to this
trilogy Jose Johnny valet John Nielsen
did a lot of stuff jerilyn Powell also
did a lot of stuff caves sequence oh
yeah there was a custom lighting effect
that was awesome I just have to say
thank you guys so much
both of Joseph and jerilyn Jackie and
Johnny Jimmy Jimmy and Jacqueline Jeremy
and oh thank you guys so much for making
this game I really do appreciate it
thank you guys for taking the time out
of your day to make something like this
it was scary how accurate some of these
things went on over here
oh we got a hard ass over here don't we
we're completing the game without
switching the easy mode you've earned a
little teaser for the third bag
the demons back in mark body mark is out
his way to intervene but what damage YTV
do before mark magazine halt but can
mark a meet defeat a demon
what does the seamen's plan why is he
targeting markiplier twice in a row he's
here perhaps a bigger story here well
the third game butts have to be all
emotional and stuff if I have such a
powerful adversaries mark will eat help
there's only one man capable or a box I
was wondering I can't wait that was
awesome sincerely like I didn't you know
thank you guys so much for taking the
time to make these games for me like I
know that some people are like oh it's
just an RPG maker it's simplistic but
people pour their hearts and souls into
these games and and that means the world
to me because like I haven't had a
chance to sit down and do a vlog about
PAX East but it really does touch my art
when people go out of their way
especially people that like drive from
miles away to come see me and and that
means a lot you know it means a lot to
know that even after all this time and
even after all the times that I say you
know thank you it never wears thin on
you guys and it always comes from the
heart because and I just saw I said I
just saw Jax jacksepticeye's vlog about
his packs time the PAX East and I was
touched because it was like that was his
experience was like one of the first
times I went to a convention but except
when I first went to a convention I had
many less sub so I didn't experience it
like he did and just you could see the
childlike wonder in his eyes as he was
describing his experience and like
that's what's really cool about this and
I get to meet these amazing people like
this and I get to have these
opportunities and I get people that look
into my life so much and like cherish
the things that I do that they make a
game about in reference many many things
about both the game and my friends and
that's what's really special to me and
that's why that's why I always love love
love love playing these games I know
they get wordy and I know they get talky
and I know they get reference II but
that's what makes it great you know I
get the chance to look back on all the
cool things that happen so anyway I'll
stop rambling for now just thank you
guys so much for watching thank you guys
for making these games I know there are
games out there that I have not played
yet I'm slowly whittling through them I
don't want to do these too often but
just thank you everyone who has made a
game for me thank you from the bottom of
my heart I really truly appreciate it
and I thank you guys so much for
watching and enjoying them so thanks
again everybody and as always the big
guns and horses came too please the
monkey doesn't further make up monkey
out of me
[Music]